did she get one of these
no thank you do you even know what this
is
it is a fitness orb and it has
completely changed my life
forget everything you thought you knew
about ab workouts
done
this ab workout is specifically designed
to strengthen your core
sorry all right
numerous health benefits
strengthens your back
better performance in sports
more enjoyable sex
you're not having sex
plus
improved your reflexes
i would have caught that okay you know
what uh how much is that
uh it's only 25 bucks wow
um
okay
oh
why pay more
to sit next to old [ __ ] claws over
there when you can sit on my lap phyllis
is only
pretending to be a man i'm the real
thing
sit down on my lap and there will be no
doubt oh okay no it's not it's not like
penis-wise hello little boy what's your
name michael it's me kevin
phyllis says i'm too big for her lap oh
i am so sorry that phyllis hates you
and hates your body
but santa remembers a reindeer that was
just a tiny bit different as well when
can i sit on your lap right now come on
over here big boy
there we go oh my god
that's really comfortable
what would you like a christmas little
boy
i don't know
i i didn't know you were gonna ask me
that wow what did you think was going to
happen i didn't know
nobody's ever let me sit on their lap
before just say some toys please can you
give me some choices cause i really
don't want to mess up on this list
kevin come on
what about if i tell you the things i
don't want okay get off get off
oh gee god i didn't even get to tell you
what i wanted okay you know what you get
you got a thousand helium balloons
attached to you so santa doesn't have to
go through this again
awesome
all right who did this
i'm not mad i just want to know who did
it so i can punish them what are you
talking about
uh someone uh forged medical information
and that is a felony okay whoa all right
because that's a pretty intense
accusation how do you know that they're
fake uh
leprosy
flesh eating bacteria
hot dog fingers
government-created killer nano-robot
infection
you did this didn't you absolutely not
yes you did you know i didn't i know it
was you okay fine you know what i'm
gonna have to interview each and every
one of you
until the perpetrator makes him or
herself known
and until that time
there will be no health care coverage
for anyone
killer nano robot it's an epidemic
[Music]
did i ever tell you why i left scranton
yeah i didn't think i had
well
it was all about pam
yeah i mean
she was with roy and uh
i just couldn't take it
i mean i lost it dwight
i couldn't sleep
i couldn't concentrate on anything
and then weird stuff like
food
had no taste
so my solution was to move away
it was awful
and it is something that i wouldn't wish
on my worst enemy
and that includes you
hey
there he is hey meredith how you feeling
i never thanked you for coming to the
hospital oh please it was my pleasure
while we all came so well i really
appreciate you coming i'm singling you
up
anyway i have this sharpie uh-huh and i
was wondering if you could sign my cast
can you write where i can read it oh
yeah
i'll read this when i go
all right
you